[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah pardon c'était le formidable groupe
américain actuel bon euh mon cher Pierre
on te dit imitateur mais tu es tu es
beaucoup mieux que ça tu es un inventeur
euh oui mon cher Momo mon cher euh
pardon sachat enfin si tu veux je trouve
que des imitateurs il y en a beaucoup
c'est bien je ne les critique pas c'est
formidable mais si tu veux il a moi ce
que j'aime ce sont les choses réalistes
tu vois si je voulais imiter j'en ferai
vraiment des kilos tu vois mais ce qui
est difficile c'est de faire réaliste tu
vois par exemple si je veux imiter un
petit oiseau de la Forêt
Noire formidable tu vois et c'est pas
fini ça c'est dur mais alors je peux
faire aussi la sirène d'un PACBO qu' EST
DANS LA Brim comme la mergaise il est
dans les smou tu
[Applaudissements]
vois
tu
vois bien ou alors les claquettes comme
j
[Musique]
Kelly ah ou moi j'ai essayé je suis
jamais arrivé à ça ah ou non mais c'est
pas simple mais par exemple le marteau
piqueur
[Applaudissements]
aussi oui oui à cette heure du soir oui
non ça réveille mais il faut le faire le
plus mesdames mesmoiselles messieurs mon
cher Sacha c'est de faire les quatre
ensemble non non arrête arrête arrête tu
vas tu vas faire sauter la sonau c'est
pas possible non non